he was drafted in 2013 at just 18 years
old and he has spent his entire NBA
career in Milwaukee talk about loyalty
in 2021 he led the Bucks to their first
title in 50 years now the Basketball
Star is teaming up with Wall Street
investor John cadunas of kalamo's
Investments for a first of its kind
partnership they created an investment
fund aimed at making investing more
accessible and 10 percent of the profits
will go to charitable causes like
Financial Education First on CBS
mornings Jonathan tacompo and John
cadunas joins us right now how you guys
doing good morning
all right so uh Giannis you are a very
very successful basketball player why
take this lead into Finance
um I just want to create access ask for
people uh help people as much as I can
to educate them and try to teach them
about financial literacy I think it's
very important is something that uh
fortunately uh you know growing up I
didn't have I had nobody you know uh
uh sit me down and then teach me how to
invest my money and guide me through uh
my own Journey you know I was 18 when I
came to the states
uh you give it a 18 year old with a lot
of millions of dollars uh you don't
really know what to do with it yes uh
and it's a it's a real thing and you see
like 70 of professional athletes you
played yeah that go they go broke yeah
they go broke I mean I read at one point
you had your your money in 50 different
banks is that true 50 different banks
it's not exactly true but it was a lot
of banks kind of true explain your
process what were you doing why did you
do that you know I was 18.
um
came to the states
learn how to you know get my own driving
less how to open a bank account I did
everything by myself because my parents
did not come with me when I came to the
state so when I went to the bank I was
just curious I told them like okay if I
put my money in the bank and then
checking account is everything's gonna
be safe they said no it was again got
into you 250 000 I'm like I have more
than two I'm putting more things yeah so
I'm like okay I'm gonna go and open five
six seven other bad account to put my
money there because I always wanted your
money to be safe yeah yes and I would
always start don't put all your eggs in
one box
but obviously there's safer ways and
most better ways to um do the same thing
now but I was just you trying to figure
it out on your own yeah but that was the
only option for me right the time that's
why John what you're doing is so
important you call it it's an ESG
investment fund which means exactly what
so uh ESG is a form of sustainable
investing and uh Environmental a social
and governance uh in what are our
portfolio managers invest in and it's a
it's a huge part of the market right now
it's in the news a lot yes
um people look everybody has issues with
trying to save the world uh with making
sure that child labor laws are in place
they're not abusing them having
diversity on boards and stuff so there's
a process of measuring
companies
especially public companies and how they
follow all these roles and when I met
Giannis through a mutual friend and I
met Giannis and his uh
agent but we hit it off and we had a lot
of shared values yeah in terms of family
Community financial literacy environment
but values is what matters to you
Giannis that's one of the reasons why
you're doing this you have two sons of
your own
and what you want to pass on to them and
help others who may not who you don't
want to make the same mistakes that you
did
um
at the time I don't think there were
mistakes you know you know because
that's all I had that's the knowledge I
had yeah good point but uh you know my
father never taught me about investing
he didn't because he didn't know he
didn't know right you know and now he's
the number one thing I'm going to teach
my kids I want my kids before they even
get the First doll to know how to
make a dollar two yeah you know yeah and
why just do it to my kids how can I you
know give people give people access to
be able to invest what's the best lesson
you've learned when it comes to money
that uh money make money faster than
people can
you
probably make money faster than most but
uh but John I mean for people who are
like Giannis who are coming into the
market one of the things I love about
this investment vehicle it's not just
going to be available to retail
investors be available to institutional
investors so if somebody is like Giannis
maybe doesn't have the level of assets
that he has but wants to think about
investing smartly what should they be
thinking well what are the the main
reasons we wanted to do this we wanted
to have Outreach to as many people as we
can so there's three different types of
funds there's the regular open and
mutual fund there's what you call a
usage so we can sell it overseas and
there's an ETF that we're going to be
ringing the bell this afternoon into New
York Stock Exchange a closing about four
o'clock where anybody even if they have
25 can invest in a share so we wanted to
be able to the Outreach for anybody to
start learning it's part of the whole
financial literacy anybody can buy
whether it be a huge institution a
sovereign wealth fund that will buy
Millions at a time or a child wearing
his jersey because he's a fan and wants
to start learning about it you can put
in and buy one share at approximately
25. it's a beautiful thing you're doing
I have to talk a little bit about
basketball Wes Eden that's right who's a
big cheese over there at the Milwaukee
Bucks who I think is one of the best
human beings on the planet
um says really wonderful things about
you how you behave on and off the court
and I think the big question many people
want to know do you plan to you've been
with the Milwaukee Bucks do you plan to
stay with them forever and please speak
into the microphone
go ahead Yiannis
on my sleeve and I I really appreciate
people that gave me opportunity to
change my life my my parents life my
kids life uh and I don't take that for
granted I don't take that lightly and
the first time I was you know able uh to
leave and be afraid and to go join
another team I chose to stay with them
walking back because they helped me they
got me through all this plus when I was
18 year old I I knew no better so uh
that I will always have that in my mind
in my heart and uh as long as I'm
healthy as long as they want me to be a
part of the boy box organization I would
love to uh stay there nice
ladies oh man uh Giannis and John thank
you both very much this is such an
incredible project I thank you for
bringing everybody be honest let me get
there come on man yeah be honest you
should have seen Nate do a little strut
over to you
baby that was a heavy duty okay okay
Nate careful than that
thank you thank you guys both for coming
we'll be right back